what's up gamers where am I
dokoni deskah Nihon Nia Remus that's
right it's that time of year again with
perfect audio quality time for me to
review Lawai japan edition leave your
entries in really close i don't have at
all cables I'm just okay tomorrow it's
dress up as your favorite youtuber at
school I couldn't afford the actual
shirt so I made what get your parents
Guardians permission have them contact
me my wife and I would like to buy you a
real shirt ah that's so nice represent
send this lady this young lady all the
shirts she wants wait what am i doing
that is the cutest thing I have seen in
my entire life I hope in humanity
restored everyone thank you sweetiepie
submissions made this for Felix how do I
send in to and Kroger I see 100 million
I saw this I was like no that can't be
real and I guess it is real this is
perfect because I'm in Japan so now I
can be super weeaboo all I need is a
fedora and I got the whole package for
real this is insanely cool I would love
to get this however you're trying to
send me a weapon you know that right
it's not so easy I don't know what the
postal office will say about that if you
live in Japan or UK and deliver very
cold thank you very much dudes that are
into cars are just a male version of
horse girls the truth hurts Jordan oh
yeah Jordan likes cars what a total
horse girl got him yeah I never liked
cars that much I don't really get it
they go vroom vroom epic epic cool I do
like my new sign that's the only car
that truly means something for me boy do
I miss my new sound - ow
even council of water sheep left me also
pity pie
oh hey I also killed them in VR a lot of
when people read into the Minecraft or
be like oh maybe it's like or in last in
five episodes ago you did this and maybe
that means blah blah but it's literally
just me messing around
wow that's weird they just disappeared
ah that's hot there was a climate strike
oh my god cringe the climate can't hear
you
what's the point I really hope that
reference isn't YouTube rewind that'd be
funny like bring back Will Smith in the
beginning just go yeah that was she
Marge said checking Phyllis computer
homework folder creeper porn why would I
have a homework folder oh I get it
epic bouncer bout set bread bread dead
Phil Phil ate filet filet epic really
this is the top loaded Khmer
congratulation omedetou feel like that's
hilarious YouTube did a newpsie
PewDiePie no subscribers Thomas has
never seen such BS before when the enemy
protagonist is almost dying but when the
theme song starts playing epic where are
the memes about me this is supposed to
be my pie I can always tell if I made
bad videos a week the less memes it is
about me the worst videos then a rooted
runner the girl who actually went in I
don't know if it's a good idea to
celebrate that what everyone sees what
Felix is sure that's what I see teacher
the test isn't that confusing the test
oh my god it's a Minecraft meme and I
don't understand it
oh no no I don't know is that vibe all
right away it all started with the sheep
Felix laughing at a sheep that got stuck
in the water
fixed religiously obeying commands of
counsel of beetroot and building the
dolphin coaster if I don't make
Minecraft videos in it in a while its I
want to spend more time when I'm
visiting Japan but more minecraft videos
will come the single-player one this is
the update that we deserve finally I can
play vegan minecraft what eggs aren't
vegan but why can I eat them here we go
again everyone talking about the kid
never running but what about the one
person who crust what about that one
person I wanted to get arrested huh guys
I can see like what difference does it
make I don't get it no one the guy that
finished to parkour in the minecraft
server lobby
I see no God up here other than me Oh No
[Laughter]
be careful or you call ugly at high
school wait are you saying about I was
ugly in high school so I had minecraft
noises I think I was overdue for a
haircut but I'm not entirely sure to be
honest oh look at the virgin I was doing
the spit out pays me council of water
sheep
Felix council update route payee mmm
leave your top thoughts on what's gonna
happen next
like I would love to hear your ideas so
I can steal them okay
vaccinate your kids I'm not running a
frickin daycare center down here
thanks Satan your epic what should i do
down below thanks Satan
I'm not moving that direction with my
hand okay
people who turn on the shower while
being directly under it without shaking
bit temperature first people who [ __ ] at
school
ooh yeah I think those two compare I've
never seen such bravery being measured
so balanced incredible sometimes when I
just feel like I don't care anymore
I just go to schools and [ __ ] in them oh
my god can't believe amazing Photoshop
incredible job even the hand oh my god
that's hot I'm inside minecraft how old
is minecraft ten years old
epic yeah I'm freak minecraft oh no I
heard about this the lube cat has passed
away it's time to go
was I a good girl no I'm told you were
the best
the original pose was so sad I'm here to
say loved has left us who knew a picture
would become so special also Luke was
Canadian and a girl my friend cried all
day and happy to have posted you sister
alright I'm not I don't know why I like
it dave is still so funny I'm sorry I
don't mean to me when my dog dies in
Minecraft but I can't scream because
it's 4:00 a.m. I don't care I would let
that dish highest roar I don't know if I
could be too loud here yet
but that like times 100 why is Felix
making me wait sorry can you give me any
my eyes ah the real reason we went to
Japan for cosplaying someone err played
dudes Minecraft part one at lunch the
kid who did this got two days ISS but
he's a bully
wait why did ISS is that like suspension
Jesus Christ careful he's a hero F what
is ISS International Space Station okay
that's pretty epic that's a good school
I know this is late but rest in peace my
boy Brett oh no I don't know what to
tell you guys but I've been dabbling
into black minecraft magic and maybe
friend's boyfriend return it worked in
Full Metal Alchemist
so therefore a working Minecraft my
father was a beetroot Wow
we look so much alike my dad said that
he watched a Minecraft series and he
enjoyed it
and I wonder what he thought where's
daddy ha ha yay where's mommy yay all
right dudes where are the animals dark
magic minecraft epicness coming right up
okay it's fine they're gonna be fine
they're just chillin with Satan for a
little while me at half a heart that was
that's buddy damn it on the flight here
I this is a 12-hour flight to Japan and
I was looking forward to playing
Minecraft the whole way and then my
laptop I didn't have my charger it was
the worst day of my life
I was planning to build a second
meatball it was like finally I can't
build my second people this is so sad I
know we will never see the second
meatball so you see that's where gaming
year began that smile that damn smile I
think we're going for gaming here at
this point might as well it's been fun
obviously there's been more of the
regular content coming back in but I
want to mix it mix if exceeds mixi
expectation reality there it is everyone
everyone knows we're raiding the Vatican
on 24th of December maybe Easter is
better is Easter better anything red
with black stripe exist are beautify
submissions I have achieved comedy wow I
do want to make like a compilation at
some point is there a subreddit for like
all the
pies at stripes or whatever I have zero
clue how felix evolved from this to this
all right perfect takedown cancel baby
I did as you commanded guys we're just
getting started on the minecraft lore
it's like the anime saga when you really
think it's ended there's a whole new
chapter and legacy living on the alright
you yeah if you if you watch enemy you
understand what I mean sheep turns it
epic oh yeah of course of course I
checked the a an Asian sheep always
check edge of [ __ ] number one rule of
Sweden check the edge of [ __ ] Watership
first episode what does she plaster
what can you do that finally the Game of
Thrones crossover will happen this is
what I was talking about with the anime
analogy you think it's just a normal
sheet but then 20 seasons later and it's
a dragon sheet you can still trick it
thank you for rescuing me dude aw geez I
left my phone can we go back
nah man too dangerous I'll get you a new
one
nuts I was going to show you what's
happening happened - bangs - him nothing
happened to it it's here in Japan that's
why I'm here to find it epically Bank
died in my VR fever dream he then came
back with the nametag it's easy why am I
wearing these I don't have to wear these
at all nuts I was going to show you how
to understand memes with just one panel
damn it we were so close lost dog has
seen episode 33 7 huge reward there are
a few hints if you look close close
earlier in the episodes that's right if
I ever play Minecraft
I will marry PewDiePie but Jack and too
late
gamer sorry sorry we can marry each
other in Minecraft Jack who's the [ __ ]
for but cracker right it's still open
I think we're safe
Elon Reeves everyone my oh wow that's
pretty epic damn pity pie and
CaptainSparklez should make a minecraft
parody song guys can you keep a secret I
already recorded on my rap song before I
came to Japan and Dave helped me out and
he makes it he's working on it right now
so it will be out soon it's pretty
awesome
this is my favorite subreddit me my
friend
peopie submissions yeah the free kick I
understand the judgement of my life
choices don't knock it until you try it
I haven't tried it though but don't like
it oh wow that was supposed to be my
minecraft girlfriend wasn't it
not bad not bad at all we're gonna plant
a ton of trees but I need a lot of
youtubers epic wait did he actually go
to the Amazon of course mr. Bies I am by
your side I will plant at least a couple
of trees you have my brofist Felix when
Jack swore Felix when he saw how old are
these stop don't build IKEA power to out
of wool when it thunders it could burn
down wool easily burns and IKEA power is
very tall so we construct easily do you
think a mayor lightning struck will take
down the most glorious creation of all
time after meatball number 2 IKEA tower
will rise and there's nothing you can do
to stop it I assume whoever wrote this
with some sort of barrel okay I know
what I'm doing
thank you for your concern however do
not care downvote your knots then go
away he said
oh that hi Felix
why do you never show me in video why do
you always talk about red shut ok gamers
here's a little story I've been diabetic
for 12 years and I finally just got my
PewDiePie palm stick I'm so excited
I hope Felix see my new pub let's go
gamers that's awesome that's so cool I
don't know how a pump works is that to
get your insulin epic that's really cool
did you make perfect Minecraft series
yes what does it cost my sanity it will
all make sense in the end all the pieces
will come together like Doctor Strange
hey please get a mule this has a speed
of uragan an ability carry chest like
Bernie you get one by making horse and
donkey go freaky Tiki Tiki if you get
one name it journey journey on a
guardian Jorgen here early journey I
love that epic name oh my god all the
environment strikes
rest in peace mother nature she was like
father to me I loved her like a son yes
in the chat for environments I
understand why it would strike the
environment like they can't listen how
many times I gotta say this mother earth
isn't real cringe haha that's so cool
is it Nate ryx again Nate ryx amazing
that's so cool the first ever dolphin
rollercoaster thank you very much Marcia
Felix why did you buy a creeper costume
it will all make sense freakin awesome
oh god remember when I told people on
the official d-lab that pitov I lived in
my town and this is my restaurant and
not many people believe this well he
actually came in again tonight thanks
for the pig beautified such a nice guy
oh that's nice thanks for crouching over
for the picture as well I appreciate it
I like how he said I was a nice guy I
literally went okay so now I get free
beer right he was so nice he kept asking
for three things he probably has crab
meat damn he makes pubes because I am
other girls try to impress their
husbands Marcia try to impress Billy
nice yeah Wow Thank You Felix and I were
sitting separately on the plane and
randomly Smith to put each other at the
same time why didn't they places next to
each other so weird
I named him Jim after my favorite
youtuber mr. B's like that don't finish
the episode mr. B's just just stop
watching there please black magic needs
to resurrect it
my theory was correct and here we go
here we go okay what if they did lied
about working for what the Sheep what if
it wanted you to overthrow the council
what if it was all a setup by Peggy and
now you gave biggie what it wanted the
council didn't turn red to warn you
about the Redstone it turned red to warn
your body through council knew all along
oh my god when you make a cobblestone
generator and it works on the first try
big brain basically me first you're
against it no oh this is awful
Dabu no I can't laugh at this Sweden
during hey don't attack me I'm Swedish
yes pretty much goddamn hey our tactics
work then and it works now it's like
history that we don't talk about in
Sweden be through dangerous rent makes
everyone go away requires sacrifices
made false messiah warns Felix about
potential dangers Swedish colors spends
friend did nothing wrong the
reincarnation of God well then why did
they perish so quickly fools the people
who can understand V through language
people who can understand PewDiePie's
rating system but what won't want pity
fights father won the best coach 2019
congratulations well done puppy first
page of Google second page of Google
Rula I missed you so much
can I picked you stop Google page 1
Google page 2 Wow I think that's Google
page 20
Council of B through web one way valve
will beautify council to be true whereby
bang bum Felix speaking language of gods
oh god I miss playing minecraft in
Sweden it's forbidden by the law to be a
criminal don't attack me I'm Swedish
there you go gamers this is why I am
invincible thank you very much and thank
you for watching this episode of the Y
gamer merch epically hey remember a
while back when at last I was in Japan I
was like oh I would really like to live
here well we bought a house here yeah so
we're just here for a couple days
setting up that's why I don't have my
whole setup and everything is terrible
but I did want to just say thank you
it's the dream come true
in a way and yes bro finger see you
tomorrow bye bye well you haven't tried
to pursue me later today after 50
million our troops flash down just down
it's still relevant just down a bit